hi there Steve Kaufman here again to
talk about language learning online and
in particular to talk about the online
language teacher I think this is a
rapidly growing phenomenon more and more
independent teachers of many different
languages are either setting up their
own shop whereby they teach online via
Skype or similar you know video exchange
systems but Skype is probably the most
popular so these people either are
independent or they are involved in
websites that group these teachers and
offer them to learners such as I talked
to you which is the one that I have used
and you know while we offer native
language tutoring at linked in many
languages we don't have tutors and and I
think that we need to do a better job
with how we offer the opportunity for
our our members to interact with native
speaking tutors but leaving that aside
it recently in Polish in Ukrainian in
Greek now I have gone to high talkie so
I want to talk a little bit about the
experience my experience I have also
taught English via Skype what do I think
are the prerequisites or the ideal
conditions or how should the online
language teacher best help the learner
now I talk of course from my perspective
the way I like to learn so I think what
are the goals of the online language
teacher to me I think the number one
objective is to be encouraging to the
learner that's the absolute most
important thing because most of the
learning is not done during the lesson
most of the learning is done outside the
lesson reading or listening or otherwise
trying to engage with people in the
language remember it's your attitude and
it's the time you spend that's going to
determine your success in language
learning so if the teacher the online
language teacher can encourage create a
positive attitude
make the learner want to come back to
you as a teacher or make the learner
want to spend more time with the
language that's the number one goal to
encourage the learner the second most
important goal is to give the learner a
chance to speak because we have ample
opportunity to listen I have I less than
an hour a day while doing other chores
washing dishes driving a car that's
resizing and I can read but I don't have
much opportunity to speak some teachers
think that it's their job to do a lot of
speaking I think that is not so useful
so a good online language teacher has to
know how to bring out the learner what
is the learner interested in let the you
know ask the learner questions to
encourage the learner to speak and the
teacher should not speak very much I
don't think that the hour or half an
hour that we have online with the native
speaker is there in order to teach the
grammar or teach the vocabulary because
a lot of that however much you explain
or teach is gonna be forgotten anyway of
course you can add so the teacher should
answer any questions that the learner
has but I think the main goal should be
to engage the learner and have the
learner speak the target language I'm
also not a great fan of reading along or
role-playing for example recently I had
my Greek tutor say okay today we're
gonna do role-playing and she sent me a
sort of a series of words having to do
with what you say at the airport and
passport show me your documents baggage
and so forth and so on and she started
she sent me this and said have a look at
that have a look at this and then so
where are your documents were gonna
pretend you're going through customs I
said no thank you I'm not gonna do that
I want to talk about things that are
meaningful to me in fact I'm not now
going through customs so I don't want it
10 that I'm going through customs I
would like to talk about things that are
interesting and I have lots of things
I'm interested in and I'm sure we can
find lots of topics to discuss so fine
he had no problem with that so we
reverted back to our conversation mode
after our discussion and this is another
important point she the tutor writes all
of my mistakes down either immediately
into a Google document which you know I
can see online if I want to follow along
and she's writing these things down
which is something useful because if the
tutor introduces new vocabulary I can
never understand anything when I hear it
the first time if I read it I at least
understand what she's saying or hear it
better because I can read it but then I
get this list of my words and phrases
afterwards and then I review them in
link now given whether you're in link or
not the accessibility of online
dictionaries means to me at least you
don't have to put the English or the
translation into this this just here are
the words and phrases you have trouble
with I get the report and I study it so
then I looked at her list of things that
one says at the airport related to
checking in and and going through
security and sovereigns on so I went
through it and I of course had to erase
all the English then I imported it into
link and studied it and I thought to
myself this is useful information it
would be even better if she could record
it which I told her and she said yeah
that'd be great I can do that and that's
it occurred to me to that even better
with this information if she could make
some kind of repetitive story or even a
bunch of sentences where the vocabulary
repeats and she records it this again
gives me an opportunity to review this
content reading and then listening more
than once especially if the vocabulary
repeats so again the idea here is that
the to her the online tutor is someone
who should be encouraging the learner to
learn maybe providing learning
content that the learner can review
afterwards ideally with with a recorded
voice so this can have this can be for
example items of specific vocabulary as
in the case of the airport or if it's
issues of grammar again maybe the online
tutor can create some sample sentences
sentences where if it's a verb the same
ideas are expressed in different tenses
or different persons you know with
recording so then the learner can go off
and work on this material all of this
then leads to the idea that the exchange
with the online tutor is this
opportunity for the learner to speak for
the learner to get stimulated it becomes
certainly in my case sort of a milestone
I want to improve for my next engagement
for me
typically three four times a week an
hour each time is ample in fact if it
weren't for the fact that I'm going to
creep in you know a month and a half
from now I would speak even less because
I find that I have to engage with with
the language through reading and
listening and and then if I have a few
opportunities a week to to speak you
know that serves the purpose I don't
think you learn just through speaking at
a later stage when I'm better of course
I eventually need to speak a lot but if
you speak three four hours a day online
with the online tutor that can become
quite expensive I am hoping that I'll
reach a level where when I'm in Crete
and this is maybe a bit unrealistic I
can sit around with some locals drink a
bit of yuzu and speak Greek for three
four hours that would be really
meaningful this is what I was able to do
when I went to Prague for my Czech or
that I went to l'viv for my Ukrainian
and I was getting had the opportunity
for a lot of face to face conversation
and there you really develop
that fluency through using the language
a lot the difficulty on Skype is that
it's you know you're paying for an hour
or whatever it is the connection often
is not ideal so it's more difficult to
clearly hear what the person is saying
so so I think I think the I online tutor
therefore has to be realistic in terms
of what can be achieved aim at
encouraging for example if the online
tutor doesn't quite hear what the
learner is saying or if the learner
totally mispronounces a word or doesn't
say the word correctly the worst thing
the online tutor can do is sort of go
huh you know and I get that sometimes
sorry I didn't say it correctly
instead the tutor has to find some way
of indicating that he or she didn't
understand and try to get the learner to
say it again or if he or she can't make
an effort to try to understand what the
person is saying from the context and
start to use some of that vocabulary
because to summarize them number one
goal is to encourage the learner so that
the learner leaves the online lesson
more motivated to learn not less and
second of all to get that person to
speak and then however badly the person
did or thinks they did to then encourage
them and tell them how well they did
again with the intention of getting them
to spend more time with the language and
come back again so there you have a a
quick rant on the role of the online
language tutor if you like these videos
please subscribe bye for now
[Music]